all right thanks to Ali laforce and to
Jason Tatum and look who's in the studio
now Luca donic guest and and look I need
to explain something because so for you
folks out there who said how can they
have Luca donic in the studio if nobody
knew who made the all stars until we
unveiled it right here look he's in town
to play the Hawks put the invite out hey
you've been at the top of the fan vote
if if possible love to have you here if
you make it you made it you're here we
appreciate it so also welome barata
kakis
so want y'all Master English first what
did he just what did he just try to say
how are your brother yeah oh okay very
good all right no it was so so he said
yeah so we're looking so we're looking
at your numbers uh look career-high in
scoring this year in assists in
three-point percentage how do you think
you've improved year toe to this point
Luca
uh I don't know really how but uh I know
we got to win more games uh I think
we're struggling a little bit but you
know you just got to work on everything
uh take bigger steps every year and
every year becomes more of a challenge a
couple weeks couple days ago I heard
your coach say he was going to have a
conversation with you about all the
bickering with the referees and then
last night you get thrown on have you
had that conversation with your coach
and what do you have to do to ease the
tension between you and the referees and
stay in the game yeah he got to be me
you know uh I didn't have that
conversation with coach yet but it's got
to be me uh you know you just got to
stay calm uh I'm very passionate on the
court uh of court I'm a little shy so
when I step on the court it's just a
different person uh but you know it's on
me uh I got to do it I I mean as Jason
says he says you know he says Luca was
running hot at the time and and you do
run hot uh when you play but can you
still maintain the game you want to play
and try to change that intensity level
level yeah I mean I have to do it you
know this is like I said on me and I
have to do it uh got to play with the
same passion you know I always they
always said to me uh I like your game
because you're having fun out there
you're smiling and I just think I need
to go back to that a little bit more you
know I always hear or we always hear the
European game the American game
obviously you grew up in playing in the
Euro leagues and and dominating even at
times at a young age what are the things
that you bring that you say man this is
what
everyone kind of does over there but
they don't really do it here and I kind
of brought that to this uh I think
European basketball is a little bit more
tactical than NBA you know in NBA I
don't think you have many actions uh in
Europe you almost basically every time
you go down there you have I mean on
offense you have uh some call uh but
it's just different B basketball uh I
mean basically because of the rules the
rules are a little bit different and you
know uh the talent you have in an NBA
you don't have anywhere so it's it's
really tough to play defense uh you have
Superstar almost on every team now so
it's so so much talent in this league
you know I just want to congratulate you
on making an All-Star team because I
told Ernie we were talking earlier I
think it's probably more special to make
the allstar team today because of the
mixture of the votes you know back in
men Shack days you know we didn't have
fans media players so I just want to say
congratulations cuz when you get
selected by your peers that's to me even
more special and the coaches the fans
you know they going to always pick their
favorites but when your peers uh pick
you and the coaches that's speci so
congratulations and you see you would
have bit of power forward as you stand
next to
him taller
than I was playing the the first year
hey first of all I can't guard you out
there and you can't guard me in the post
let's get I'm a good post
Defender what what is it like to realize
this dream look you came over here as a
teenager but now you're six years in at
the age of 24 and now becoming an
Allstar is is what we all expect but
what what makes the night special when
you're out there with those other guys
um because every time I'm there you know
I remember when I was a kid uh I always
Tred to to watch the allstar game uh but
they wouldn't let me my parents were let
me it was like 3:00 a.m. I had to school
uh so you know I just wanted to be in
the NBA that's all first year I didn't
know what to expect where I'm going to
be uh but I was just happy to be here
and to play basketball at the highest
level so when you were a kid and now
you're just old at 25 24 24 you're just
ancient nowadays I like when I was a kid
I'm like dude you're 24 I like that so I
tell you what's really cool for my first
experience when you walk in that room
and all these guys 24 guys you're like
wow it that the first time you did that
it would had to be incredible yeah uh
exact remember and I remember I think it
was the captain still they did the
captains I think LeBron to choose me so
uh it was me Steph LeBron yanis and yic
I think my first year so who's the guy
that when you walked in you go man
that's him like you know what I mean
like as of being growing up in Europe
now you make the All-Star team like that
first guy you said it was Kareem for you
yeah I you said it was who was for you
nobody oh my tell tell them Luka nobody
I'm here now stop it stop it was there
anyone for you yeah I would say uh I
remember my first year when I had to go
against LeBron and KD I think those two
guys really I was really excited to go
against them hey I got to ask I wouldn't
be doing my job if I didn't ask you this
because when you get online today you're
all over the place for this whatever
happened in Dallas last night with the
Phoenix Suns fan who you wanted out of
there what was what was the deal there
Luca yeah I mean it was the whole game
you know a little bit but uh I was
really frustrated you know we were
losing I twisted my ankle in the second
half so in the first half it was just a
lot of emotions uh but yeah uh probably
shouldn't have done that so when I'm
wrong I admit it so probably shouldn't
have done that but it was just the whole
game going on and you want me to show
you what to do when somebody get on your
nerves I was going to ask Chuck go ahead
go ahead hey man He Got allar Game Play
got a got a game we got to beat the I
was going to ask him what to do hey uh
you're a new dad correct yes
congratulations congratulations so how's
that going for you great what's what's
the name Gabriella Gabriella how old two
months he's going to be months how how's
your how's your diaper changing game oh
it's great is it really yeah because
these guys are pretty good we look we've
all changed him in our lives but we we
actually had a contest here once uh this
had
oh that was actually
chocolate it was a melted candy bar but
Chuck almost Spain it didn't you did God
I I did I blacked out for a split second
that was crazy I like the mustache yeah
oh yeah that's when I was going through
little spe that's going back a few years
oh man that's going back right that's
probably my first couple years here yeah
no doubt Luca donic congratulations man
we're happy for you and again appreciate
you coming by here so we could share the
news you thanks man I appreciate you
thank you take bre not yet not yet I got
you
though